welcome to this session
um I'm Mohit I'm Dr Mohit mazumdar and I
have a PhD in computational biology and
I'm an expert in computational
structural biology and I have several
Publications to
which I have worked throughout my
research and Industry career helping
some research groups and during also my
PhD work so today we are meeting to
discuss and to learn about some of the
aspects of structure prediction
so as we all know and it would be great
uh if all of you can also introduce
yourself in this chat and and we can
have maybe a better interactive session
here
um as I'm also requesting that if you
also have a protein structure that you
want to predict in your mind and if you
can share the link we can perhaps take a
look at that also in the session so it's
an opportunity for those who are
actually doing something related or
would want to learn about protein
structure prediction and how to use the
alpha fold and more importantly uh what
next after that like if how to validate
what what have you predicted is this
making sense on or not
uh so please feel free
to share uh those information you can
send it to me using direct message the
protein sequence of your interest and we
can take a look at that uh during the
today's session and uh we'll try to be
trying to be I will try to do this
together and if you have those softwares
installed it would be great to do this
in sync which would be to have at least
Chimera installed so it's a
visualization software UCSF Chimera
um so if you're on Mac then you can use
the X version camera X which also has
this capability to predict structure
from the interface which is Incorporated
in the Macintosh version Mac version
and the one that we have on Windows
which we will also take a look so I'm
having I have both the systems Mac and
windows today I'm using two logins so in
case you facing difficulties and you
have any questions feel free to ask
independent of the platform now about
the session so Alpha fold
and Alpha fold I think we've been
discussing this for a while and uh
also we have this ongoing training
program going on and I'm hoping that
some of the participants from the
program whom we are working with
throughout the sessions and mentorship
uh have also joined today's session and
we will look forward to their questions
uh and in today's session we after this
wonderful introduction we have the
demonstration and some of the concepts
that I wanted to discuss about some of
the basis of what we are doing and what
uh is different and then we have also a
guest lecturer Dr Punit I'm hoping that
he'll be able to join he's running he's
kind of busy but he he said that he
would be able to join and answer some of
the questions that our participants have
going through his sessions during the
program
all right so let's uh start with that
and uh again
um yes Sarah hi Sarah
yeah we can try with your sequence it's
just that uh there's one limitation with
sequences again I should tell you this
that uh for predicting sequences of you
know
um which are larger in size in length
the number of amino acids they hold
um is kind of uh directly proportional
to the time that is it is going to take
so usually the predictions run on GPU
and CPU still because there are a lot of
people using this uh so the prediction
would take an hour and sometimes more so
we will go through that entire process
and uh yes Sarah we will have that so I
have worked on this on the on the
project and uh we will schedule a
meeting maybe tomorrow or day after to
discuss your project and uh what are the
other the next things because I think it
is mostly about mutations and mutations
are so important in in the current ERA
where we're looking at the translational
aspect by looking at genomic data
information and we are looking at
the mutations and what are the
implications in the structure so Alpha
fold is one of the way to look at one of
the snapshots but obviously today we are
going to discuss that what is actually
required to be able to make sense of
such a project where you're trying to
understand what would be the implication
of the mutation on the structure which
could be a single mutation which usually
will not cause any change major change
in the structure if you are modeling it
and just replacing one residue with
another but uh in in folding and in
functional implication how that change
in residue can cause the change in
interaction network of the entire
protein and have a devastating effect or
some new features so yeah uh all right
so as you know
Alpha 4 2 and I am hoping that you all
are aware of what Alpha fold is because
uh we also have covered it at one of our
free webinars if you have not then uh
you can ask that team to share that
video with you where we have also shared
a video by the team by Alpha 4. so Alpha
fold 2 uh af2 was the star of cast 14.
um and what is cast 14 it's the
bi-annual structure prediction
experiment so what they use is that they
used Noble uh Noble deep learning and
you have to predict the structure of
many difficult protein targets at a near
experimental resolution uh so I hope
that you understand resolution when I
say resolution it means that
um at what detailed how much detail we
got from those experiments and what
level of accuracy in this Con in the
context of alpha 4 prediction is the is
the closest to the native structure and
we do that by comparing structures and
today we are going to learn about that
as well that how do we compare structure
what is the statistical
statistical value that is important to
understand that how 90 percent similar
and how 80 percent similar what is root
mean squared deviation all of that so
now coming back to the point where what
I was trying to say is that that how
will the availability now
um with Alpha fold and other softwares
you have this option and to predict so
predict structure of the proteins and
there are decent accuracy and they're
close to they say that it's close to the
near experimental decipitation so now
there's an availability of high
resolution structures how it is going to
impact biology
so first uh structure alone does not
provide the biochemical function of the
protein nor can Alpha fold 2 predict the
phenotypical function which is often the
result of complex interplayer protein so
there could be rnas there could be dnas
there could be metabolites which which
could give us the complete picture now
uh that's why one of the key steps for
doing this is the first step which is to
get the primary structure and then from
that three-dimensional structure you try
to model protein protein interactions by
looking at the complex complex
structures and the complex interplay of
protein and DNA and all of that so that
is one of the possibility to be able to
do that model further like move go one
step ahead with this uh with this
predictions so another thing is that the
structure of a protein team can use to
enter infer its biochemical function
right that's one of the objective but it
can also you can also perform virtual
ligand screening to predict which small
molecules are drugs it might be binding
and and how it is binding so that is
again a session that is covered in the
last
uh last session where we covered a
virtual screening and softwares involved
in Virtual screening which are publicly
available anyone can start using them
download the publicly available data
from kme MBL and other repositories and
look for similar structures and use
chemi informatics and then use uh
virtual screening softwares and find out
maybe top 1000 or top 100 molecules
which you would want to dive go next
into with them using maybe docking or
other protocols now that's the strategy
usually for such uh such
um such research now uh sorry for the
maybe the image below it's not coming
high resolution but what I wanted to say
is that even though Alpha 4 2 can
accurately predict the
backbone and the side chain conformation
so here on on the screen you can see
that
um the typical confirmation uh with the
all the atoms which are uh which are
forming the
peptide backbone and different side
chain conformations so uh Alpha fold is
kind of predicting uh the backbone and
the side chain conformation and it is
for a particular conformational state
why it is for a particular
conformational State because when you
crystallize proteins and this is based
on the available experimental structures
um that protein is another snapshot of a
conformational state however a protein
can exist in more than one conformation
it can have one conformation in an
inactive State and it can have another
uh um another conformation in an active
state so if you have an active
conformation if an active conformation
is predicted by Alpha 4 2 and and then
using it to Target the inactive state it
will not work right because there is a
slight differences in the conformation
and below the image kind of shows
different conformation of a maybe a loop
region in a protein and that itself can
change the function of the protein and
the interface and you know having that
multiple confirmation allows like
dragons to bind or specificity which is
very important in drug Discovery and
Drug designing so prediction of protein
structures where the
representation
using a backbone dihedral angles that
you can see on the screen has really
recently achieved significant progress
and that's why I was I was kind of
discussing in this slide is that what we
have been you know used to is
structure-based predictions and those
predictions are based on multiple
sequence alignments and then finding
similar structures and then modeling
using them as a temp template and that
has been a common practice using either
modelers Swiss model and all of that
which works really well for closely
related proteins now uh the recent
achievements and this is where everyone
should know is on the ongoing search of
deep neural network so the deep deep
neural network uh in research in general
has a huge implications and has been
used so widely so today we are going to
review some of those aspects of how uh
the advancements have come up in deep
neural network and we
um uh and also we observed that in that
in the protein backbone angle protein
backbone angle prediction research there
has been an overall overall trend to
employ more and more complex neural
networks so instead like people are what
people are doing they are adding more
features many of these research groups
they are adding more features that might
add to more predictive power to the
neural network but then there is this
important aspect in machine learning is
that when you have it could be argued
that when you have redundant features
that could rather clutter the scenario
because more complex neural networks
needed to be counterbalanced within
within with the noise so and this is a
practical experience that people from
machine learning has maybe experienced
that when we use a lot of features then
there's a lot of noise that has to be
counted so from artificial intelligence
and machine learning perspective
perspectives problem representation and
solution approach do mutually interact
and does affect performance now that's
the key takeaway now
a case study
okay Shruti and uh all of us to send
thank you for sharing about your current
degree and your interest
um now
um as we are discussing this as a uh
understanding that uh
how uh the new
structure prediction softwares are being
used how they work so before we go into
the live session like the demonstration
the objective is to for you to
understand that what is the logic how it
works what are the advancements so
that's why we are covering this and I
hope that this is informational now
um something new so on July 2012
um a Chinese group biotech firm called
Helix halickson they launched this
software called Omega fold I don't know
if you have heard about Omega folder or
not
um this is after uh Alpha 4. so the
first computational method to predict
they they claim it to be the first
computational method to predict high
resolution protein structures from a
single primary sequence uh like uh also
what Alpha 4 does but this is uh using a
different algorithm so this new study by
this Chinese researchers fills uh much
encountered Gap in structure prediction
and inches closer to the protein folding
in nature so Omega fold is a protein
structure prediction algorithm that uses
a protein language model to predict
structure the algorithms the algorithm
Works without multiple sequence
alignments alignments which means it's
faster because
Alpha fold uh and also works on
Divergent sequences compared to Alpha
full because it uses multiple sequence
alignment and one of the reasons like if
you compare so unlike Alpha fold Omega 4
does not rely on the msas and then Omega
fold potentially better suited for
proteins that have low sequence coverage
uh like because multiple sequence
alignment when you do may help Omega
fold uh then because it it has that
additional information but it could work
without it as well so makeup sport can
predict up to like um at these almost
4000 residues and all then about the
comparison and uh this uh the like
understanding that what are the
different models that are available that
are really at par on Casp the recent
cast where there was a competition and
people are checking accuracy so the new
model developed by helixson they claim
to be outperformed Rosetta fold so
another important software in structure
prediction is was that fold
that is widely used and Achieve similar
prediction accuracy to Alpha full 2 on
the recently release structure so in a
study the researcher said that they have
used a new combination of protein
language models that allows them to make
prediction from a single residue and uh
this is uh by using geometry inspired
Transformer model trained on the protein
structure so
Omega fold leverages a deep Transformer
based protein language model that is
trained on large collections of a large
collection of unaligned and unlabeled
protein sequences to learn synchronized
pairwise representation and use it as a
feature to model the distribution of
sequences now the Omega fold the Omega
protein language model which they are
calling PLM can capture be using that
what what this does like in a layman's
term is that it uses it captures
structural and functional information
encoded in the amino State sequences
through M through embed
and then they later feed it to a geoform
uh geometric inspired Transformer neural
network to distill the structural and
physical pairwise relationship between
amino acids finally they predict out of
all of this this is quite a complex but
uh when you think about it in terms of
in terms of uh the features then it is
actually not and it's developed by
research groups so our objective is not
to do this and like develop something
but to utilize it and understand that
how they are different which tool to use
when so this is a very important aspect
of you know bioinformatics because
thousands of tools are available online
which one to use for your research and
this varies from you know problem to
problem so this is that's why biology is
kind of challenging so again that's what
I was coming at that this all of this
then finally they do a structural module
that predicts the 3D conformation of all
the heavy atoms another folding
algorithm is called the esm fold uh on
the day it uses a large scale language
model for uh protein prediction the
improvements in the language modeling uh
perplexity and the structural learning
continues through I mean they have 15
billion parameters just imagine that
it's just because of the high throughput
and this now computational power this
has been possible through uh deep neural
network and that's what I was putting
emphasis on on comparing fuel algorithms
which uses deep neural network and like
Alpha fold uses a neural uh network
based architecture and the training
proceeds based on evolutionary physical
and geometric constraints of the protein
structure so that's Alpha fold and then
you learn about
Omega fold and then esm fold and then
um Rosetta fold so all of these folding
softwares they are kind of comparable
and they could be used to you know if
you're working on a really important
problem you would want to uh take
opinion like when you visit a doctor you
have something serious you want to take
opinion from several of the doctors
similarly in in this case uh when you
are trying to predict a soft predict a
structure you would maybe uh take a look
at the other predictions and then
evaluate which is the best now this is
the overview this was the overview this
was an understanding of how we can maybe
use multiple softwares how they work
understand and then use it for our own
product